also grundsätzlich ist masken tragen
eine hocheffektive maßnahme wir wissen
dass von anderen untersuchungen habe bei
der influenza bei der grippe
das masken tragen eine hocheffektive
maßnahmen das und dass sie ist auch
jetzt bestätigt ich glaube kinder sind
eben ein teil der gesellschaft und
grundsätzlich müssen wir alle dazu
beitrag infektionsketten zu reduzieren
und das oberste gebot muss sein die
schulen sollen offen bleiben
ich persönlich glaube dass man
eigentlich sagen kann dass die kinder
bis zehn jahren relativ selbst sind bei
kleinen kindern würde ich es auch machen
aber wenn kleine kinder einmal die
masken ab machen sollten sie auch nicht
sofort aus der schule geschickt werden
sie müssen lernen damit umzugehen und
ich glaube was in ihrem beitrag buß
rausfahren es muss mehr kommuniziert
werden also die eltern müssen mit ins
boot genommen werden
meine erfahrung ist dass natürlich
eltern die eben die ganzen maßnahmen
völlig ablehnen negative haltung zu
haben diese werden auf die kinder
übertragen
visp tief gesehen gerade diese leichten
masken machen kein sauerstoffmangel das
kann gar nicht sein
wir haben selber versuche gemacht kinder
mit masken sport treiben lassen und die
sauerstoffsättigung blieb bei 100
prozent also mit sicherheit kann keiner
stern wenn er eine maske trägt das ist
sicher muss man sagen wirklich
medizinisch quatschen
aber wir müssen trotzdem darauf eingehen
und was in dem beitrag auch gut auskam
diese ganzen maßnahmen zeugen ängste bei
den kindern ich habe immer wieder hier
in der praxis auch kinder wenn wir das
wort virus kommt fangen sie an zu weinen
also das erzeugt große ängste und die
kinder müssen auf ihre art aufgeklärt
werden die müssen mit ins boot genommen
er die eltern müssen mit ins boot
genommen werden und ich glaube auch wenn
jetzt wieder die öffentliche diskussion
kommt wir müssen riesig unterscheiden
wie altes einziehen kleine kinder
kindergartenkinder grundschulkinder sind
relativ safe also dass da kind zu kind
sich ansteckt ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
extrem gering
damit müssen wir umgehen anders sieht es
in den oberschulen aus also wenn kinder
älter 12 bis 18 jahre sind da müssen wir
aufpassen und da muss immer wieder auch
online unterricht diskutiert werden und
da ist die masken pflicht sicher eine
sehr gute maßnahme dass man wenn man die
schulen offen lassen will
dass man dazu beitragen kann der kasten
jetzt noch einmal ganz konkret gefragt
haben gerade über die
sauerstoffsättigung gesprochen dass
maske tragen kann also nicht zum kollaps
von den kindern oder zu anderen schäden
führen
mit sicherheit kann maske tragen nicht
zum kollaps oder zu anderen schäden von
kindern führen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren